you talked about your upcoming tour
what's the intuition behind the show
you know this tour with so much has
happened since I've gone back out and
this is gonna be a brand new show yeah I
had the Vegas residency was successful
and fantastic kind of cool you're in one
place yeah yeah but there's something
about going into a city
um just for one night only and there's
so much I've been collecting over the
past four years of music and styles and
costumes and just ideas and I mean
you're a musician right I mean meaning
like your voice is your instrument and
being a dancer our bodies are an
instrument and so it's like this like
dance Symphony I want to create or like
a symphony of dance I know but that's
cool because what I love about what you
get to do and what I just force my fans
to enjoy is I like different genres of
music so I like doing all different
genres it's exciting and I think that's
cool that you get to implement that all
different genres of dance and music and
also having live music you know having
that like live brass section and the
live drums just with the way that the
beat hits that energy is so undeniable
and of course the costumes and the
dancing the energy if anybody's ever
been in one of my shows we we bring the
energy for sure I actually didn't know
that you're also a musician I didn't
know that you play piano I dab a little
bit the first before I dance actually I
play drums it was I was in a piece
should be banned and asked me with my
shirt off yep there it is yeah yeah
if my body looked like that I'd be naked
all the time right Jesus celebrate it
yeah no I I dabble gravity will take
hold at some point there celebrate it
I'm not gonna lie there's been a few
times this year where I'm like wait if I
just just a little don't you look
beautiful you're hot yeah you're great
um but no obviously music is is the
beginning for me for everything you know
when we dance the song inspires us the
the instruments you know
um you know if I can orchestrate the
strings and the pianos and the brass and
the winds and the percussion
um me too I love it I love it I love a
good cello yeah oh my God my favorite
thing is a piano and a cello like it's
like it's just it's magic and it's so
sad and it says something about me but
like I just really love the sadness of
it it just feels so good or passionate
yeah and it's just the low end of it
yeah it hits you right here yeah when I
I don't Tango but if I were to tango I
would picture that I look like y'all
yeah in my brain movie it would look
different
um I love that though that's so cool
that you just the musician side of you
like that's a whole nother level that
you can bring forth like in the in the
art of all of it you know that's my hope
is to really integrate the the music and
the dance you know to create that
Symphony of dance really and it's it's
uh you know and implementing that too
you know like playing instruments on you
know on stage and then going into a
dance and then having the cello player
and then dancing and Tango around them
or something and yeah it's gonna be uh a
lot of fun that's so sexy
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going
[Music]